hi everyone
[Applause]
hi I'm Jess Lee I'm a partner at Sequoia
Capital and before this I was the CEO
and co-founder of a company called poly
in the fashion tech space thank
you thank you and then before that I was
a product manager at Google Maps back in
the days when we used to print our
driving directions and carry them around
in the car so it's a while back
and I think I'm supposed to tell you a
little bit about my life story in ten
minutes
and sort of share some of the lessons
that I've learned so I'm gonna take you
back to high school I grew up in Hong
Kong I was not a very popular kid in
high school I was super into art and
drawing and anime and manga and my goal
in life was to be a go to art school and
be a graphic novelist that didn't work
out my parents are Asian and they said
no you can't go to art school so I did
it but I I was I did get pretty good
grades so I wasn't right but I maybe I
was like if you think about the totem
pole and how popular maybe I was in like
the 35th percentile of popularity but I
was I got good grades and one day one of
my teachers my English teacher came to
me and she said hey why don't you take
the AP English exam and I was like oh
but I'm not in the AP English class I I
don't qualify it she's like why does
that matter
and so she encouraged me to take the
test because she thought I was I was
good at writing and I aced it and I got
a five and who cares what my actual AP
English score was but I think that was
an important lesson for me because that
teacher taught me that sometimes there
are rules around what the requirements
are and how you're supposed to be
qualified for something and you don't
really meet them but you'd still go for
it anyway and so that's what I did and
that was a very early important lesson
that has carried through the rest of my
career
so let's fast-forward to college I ended
up not at art school but at Stanford
where I was really excited I moved this
I was moving to the US for the first
time and I had been I gotten pretty good
grades in in high school
in fact I I think I was probably in the
I think I was valedictorian at my school
but I got to Stanford and I realized
that every other kid there was
valedictorian for their high school and
so for the first time I felt like oh my
god I'm so dumb I remember feeling like
I didn't understand I wasn't as
well-read I wasn't as articulate I was
also fresh off the boat I just moved
from another country I didn't understand
any of the pop culture references or
jokes that were happening in my dorm and
I just felt completely out of place and
I wondered if it was a mistake that they
had let me into the Stanford but it was
also Stanford that I learned about this
thing called duck syndrome and I think
it applies not just to Stanford but to
all of Silicon Valley where you look at
a lake and you see these ducks floating
along and they look really peaceful and
they're like swimming along but
underneath they're paddling furiously
and they're working really really hard
just to stay stay up and look calm and
that's what I realized Stanford was like
everyone there felt a little bit like oh
I'm not the smartest person anymore I
don't get good grades anymore and all
you have to do is you have to just work
really really really hard and I end up
majoring in computer science and I don't
think the main thing I took away from my
computer science degree was actually any
of the theory or the problem sets it was
actually the ability to force yourself
to work really really really hard and be
a duck that's something I've always
carried with me because I think in
Silicon Valley in particular there's
sort of this feeling of like oh how you
do how's it going how's it going with
your company and there's this pressure
to feel like yeah I'm doing great I'm
crushing it but nobody's ever really
crushing and that was a lesson that I
learned at Stanford so I killed myself
trying to get my computer science degree
at Stanford and it was my senior year I
had accepted a job as an engineer at a
company called in to it and I was like
you know that was my path my parents
were happy again that I was not going to
be graphic knowledge I was gonna go be
an engineer but then I got a call from
Google and this is in 2004 and they said
hey we would like you to interview for
the associate product manager program
and I had never heard of a product
manager before but because it was Google
I was like you know maybe I should just
take take the interview and see what
happens but I remember feeling really
bad about it and feeling like oh man I
accepted this other offer like what
should I do with my life and so I
actually said that to pretty much all
sites I just
probably not a good thing to say in
interview but I just genuinely didn't I
mean I hadn't really interviewed very
much before so I asked all my
interviewers I'm like well you know I I
spent four years studying computer
science and I'm supposed to be an
engineer like should I do this product
manager thing and I remember one of my
interviewers looked at me funny and then
he got up and went to the whiteboard and
he wrote two words he wrote sunk cost
and he was like do you know what that
means and I was like no and he said sunk
cost is you've already given up those
four years killing yourself for your
computer science major and you're never
gonna get that time back so you should
really just optimize for your future
which is really great advice he's like
don't think about that don't let the
past decide your future just do what you
think is best going forward and I was
like wow that was a really smart guy my
second interviewer was Brett Taylor who
was in the house
Brett later went on to become the CTO of
Facebook and I just remember as I met
him he was a computer science major like
me smart and just seemed kind of
comfortable in his own skin I was like
wow I kind of want to be like that I
want to be confident and cool and so I
just remember thinking like maybe I
should just go be near the awesome
people and then I will absorb their
awesomeness through osmosis but that was
a lesson I thought okay I have to go and
find beer around the awesome people one
of my later interviewers was Marissa
Mayer who was at the time a director of
product at Google and then later went on
to become the CEO of Yahoo but at the
time she ran the APM program at Google
and I asked her the same thing should I
take this job and she said okay well
when I look back on my life and I think
about all the times I had to make a
difficult decision between two paths I
always tried to pick the more
challenging path because at least I
would learn something and I would grow
even if I failed so I would encourage
you to pick the more challenging path
and so I thought about that I thought
well I know how to be an engineer that's
what I trained for
but there's this exciting product thing
the sunk cost being around awesome
people and doing something challenging
so so that's what I did I ended up at
Google became early p.m. for Google Maps
and I had an awesome time there I
learned so so much
then one day someone showed me Polyvore
I was Polyvore was actually created by
3x yahoo engineers and they it's an app
where you can like mix and match
products and express your sense of style
and it was so much fun
I became a heavily addicted user using
it three or four hours a night and I
decided to write to the founders and
give them some of my suggestions and
complaints I said hey you know there's
this problems can you fix this I have
some suggestions and then they wrote
back and said hey these are all great
why don't you just come work here and
fix all this stuff yourself and I was
like oh you know I interesting so I met
with them and I really liked them and I
felt like that was another set of really
awesome people that I wanted to go be
near and I thought okay when else are
you gonna find opportunity work on
something that's like you thought you
were in love with where the team is
really really small and so I ended up
going to Polyvore and I remember still
again being very nervous about this
decision and then when I resigned from
Google and I went to talk to the VP of
Product Jonathan Rosenberg he said
something to me that was very
interesting he said don't worry you can
always come back and then I realized
Google hires like a hundred people a
week I could go back right so that was a
really important like lesson like when
you have that choice between something
you know that feels kind of
once-in-a-lifetime like you should grab
that because oftentimes the other path
will still be available to you in the
future right so seni way that was
another important lesson
so Polyvore it was three people when I
joined and we had so much to do and I
had never managed a human in my life
but I just kept volunteering to do
things by virtue of being maybe you know
I think as a good p.m. what you do is
you just try to volunteer and do
whatever needs to get done to move
product forward so in the beginning I
wrote code I wash dishes I answered the
phone when advertisers called I wrote
our blog just kind of did whatever
because I was the worst engineer on the
team and I thought hey you know if
there's something that needs to get done
I should probably let the real engineers
write the code and I'll just do the
other stuff and over time what happened
was
I picked up these responsibilities never
felt qualified to do them like running
marketing but what what I did was I
learned just enough to be dangerous and
enough to hire someone who was awesome
who I wanted to be around me to help
teach me how to how to be excellent at
something like marketing or sales and so
the team grew and grew and grew and fast
forward eventually all the groups in the
company were reporting to me except
engineering because I had hired so many
people and it was at that point that
some of the the original founders came
to me and they said hey you know what
we've always thought of you as a
co-founder and you've always acted like
one so we're gonna start calling a
co-founder and we're gonna give you some
of our shares and that is an incredibly
incredibly generous thing to do
and I will say that you know I have been
mentored by many great women and by many
great men but I will always be grateful
to joining Pasha and Guang way for that
very very generous act so I became sort
of an official co-founder and then
eventually I became CEO and as CEO I
learned a lot of lessons about startups
the primary one is that startups are
really really hard and again I felt that
duck paddling that duck syndrome because
I looked around and I read TechCrunch
and I read like all these different
blogs and I felt like man everyone
else's company is amazing but I have a
lot of problems my VP left like how to
fire someone like our traffic is down
this week like I just felt like was
paddling furiously it turns out that
that's true of most startups but we just
kept growing and growing and growing and
eventually we you know through lots of
ups and downs I learned a lot about how
to be a CEO probably the first I think
I'm most important lesson was that the
end of the day team and culture matter
so much you cannot always control the
outcome like you'll go through ups and
downs that are totally outside of your
control but you're on a clock you have
money that you could run out of your
funding and you have the patience of
your team and if you treat your team
really really well and you build a
culture and you surround yourself with
awesome people who want to work to get
they will give you just that little bit
of extra time when it looks like you
know probably everyone should just leave
it's not really working they'll be like
you know what I really love this culture
and I really love this teens I'm gonna
stick it out for another month or two
and then you sort of turn the corner and
so we we we kept going and eventually we
were acquired by Yahoo in 2015 and it
was actually a successful outcome
but I'm you know I know again the entire
time I just felt totally unqualified to
be doing that job but it ended very well
and so that brings me to today I have
thought about what to do next after
Polyvore and I realized that all those
lessons I learned along the way brought
me to where I am today and I decided to
go be an investor enjoying the dark side
and as I was thinking about that I
thought you know maybe should I go do
something should I try being a founder
again I spent all this time working on
being a founder and maybe I would do it
like slightly better than second time
around and then I thought about sunk
cost and I thought about well I could
always go back to that right though you
know it's now that I've done it once
maybe there will be options going
forward so I should do this thing that
seems more difficult more challenging
where I'm gonna grow and learn the most
so I decided to go be an investor I
chose Koya because I felt like if I'm
gonna go and learn the art of venture
capital I'd like to learn it from some
of the best people every person I met
there was more awesome than the next and
seemed like there would be a lot of
great osmosis for me and then you know
one of the things I'm passionate about
is helping women in tech I was a female
founder working on a product targeted at
women and it was hard to raise money
sometimes so one of the projects I work
on now is this thing called female
founder office hours where the goal is
to get all the female founders together
let go of duck syndrome for a little bit
and just like really share the stories
of how hard it is and really help
problem solve
so that's female founder office hours at
female founder dot work so that's my
story I I don't know what the next
chapter will be but I will say that the
interesting thing is when I look back on
my entire career I have felt pretty
unqualified for almost every role that
I've ever been in like I never done it
before our first time founder first time
p.m. first time CEO
first time investor but what I realize
now is that feeling of being unqualified
is exactly what you're supposed to look
for I go back to Marissa Mayer's advice
and she said pick the more challenging
path go where you're gonna grow and
learn and learning feels like being
totally unqualified so now I think when
I think about my career I always try to
think about how do I go find that really
nauseous feeling where I'm like oh I
don't know how to do this it's really
uncomfortable and that's really the
advice that I mostly wanted to share
with the group tonight go seek out that
feeling if you feel really comfortable
and like you know exactly what you're
doing it's probably time for you to do
something different
thank you
[Applause]